vous en avez assez de tourner en rond
avec toujours les mêmes films d'horreur
qu'on vous recommande dying grid est un
film australien à découvrir absolument
dying grid ça veut dire race en voie de
disparition et c'est bien ça dont il va
s'agir avec des créatures totalement
arriérées qui vont s'en prendre à un
groupe de jeunes gens le scénario semble
appeler assez classique mais ce qui est
intéressant avec ce film australien
Dying Bride c'est qu'il est réalisé par
une femme et que celle-ci a un grand
talent
quatre jeunes adultes responsables
partent sur une île de Tasmanie l'île de
Tasmanie s'est située au large de
l'Australie et ce sont des gens
particulièrement raisonnables ils
connaissent tous les codes des films
d'horreur ils savent ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire et voilà pourquoi le film
devient très intéressant c'est que les
arriérés qui vont s'en prendre à eux
vont devoir être plus malins que ces
malins jeunes gens
donc la course-poursuite est réelle
c'est un film évidemment inquiétant
qu'il faut déconseiller aux âmes
sensibles mais l'ambiance est
remarquable et les décors de ligne de
Tasmanie très peu connu sont absolument
remarquables on est dans une ambiance
inquiétante à souhait et le film
évidemment va aller de surprises en
surprise jusqu'à devenir malheureusement
ou heureusement pour les amateurs
totalement morts mais l'ensemble des
filtres reste extrêmement raisonnable et
pourtant très inquiète je vous
recommande Dying Bride
2018 ce film australien
[Musique]
[Rires]